thank you all right guys so today the in
this lecture we're going to be looking
at some of the most instructive
fragments for my games over the last
couple of years so we're not going to
look at any complete games but just the
parts that I think could be a most value
to you and I can tell you right away
that none of this is stuff that I got
right during my games
so there's only things that I learned
after the games um in the analysis
usually with my coach um so I figure you
know if it's something I couldn't figure
out and it was new to me it'll probably
be new to a lot of other people as well
so here's our first example this is my
game two years ago from the Edmonton
International against Grandmaster Victor
my high left scheme from Israel and
Victor just played this move f5 I can't
say that this move was somehow
unpleasant for me I mean the idea behind
this moves very simple actually black is
already threatening ninety six to d4
this maneuver of the night into the d4
square so that's probably what prompted
white to play the move f5 and here it's
time for black to look for a plan so
first of all I can say that this
position doesn't look like it should be
a problem for black at all right Black
has no bad pieces that's the first
indicator of a bad position is if you
have at least one bad piece you can't
say that about blacks position here in
fact maybe then Bishop on g2 can come
across as sort of a bad piece it's a
LightSquared Bishop there are a lot of
pawns on the light squares for white so
black looks fine to me but the question
is what kind of a plan should black come
up with so I'm going to ask that
question to the audience and anyone
watching at home can also try to think
you know what would they do here for
black
okay so one of our audience members
suggested pushing through this break d5
right the problem is that's a very
somatic breakthrough in the center right
sure you've got sort of a backwards deep
on quite backwards but it's under some
pressure if you could play d5 trade it
off open up the position you know maybe
you could also take advantage of white
sort of weakens kingside the problem is
when you are thinking about playing d5
you are playing trying to plant a square
that is like the best protected square
that white has on the board with every
single piece you know pointing at that
square so it's like oh you know yeah
white is pretty well prepared to meet
your d5 move I mean it's going to be
hard to ever prepare to put enough
pieces on on that square to make it to
make it ever possible to move there so I
think that that idea is out of the
question in this particular position
although you know I can understand why
you'd want to play it but it's just
given how many white pieces are on that
square it's hard to get in so you're
thinking well moving your Queen over to
b7 or a 7 you have a little problem
first of all your d6 pawn requires
protection so as soon as you move your
queen away from it you have to deal with
the loss of that pawn okay I'm going to
explain this position to guys because
it's not that easy and we're going to
try to get through a lot of examples
today so it would be helpful for black
to ask themselves here what does my
opponent want to do so what's white
going to do what's White's plan well it
turns out that White's by his f5 advance
that five move gives white space on the
King side a space advantage on the Kings
side and that's the part of the board
that white is going to try to play on
with a very typical plan
so they're going to withdraw their queen
to e2 they're going to advance their
pawn to g4 then they'll put up their
queens III to support the pawn moving up
to g5 so then their space advantage on
the Kings side will have increased then
okay it's still not enough to win the
game right they need some more pieces
there their bishop will move over to f3
this rook will swing over to the G file
this rook will swing over and suddenly
blacks position on the King side is
looking very precarious the night on e 2
can be transferred over by e to g3 to h5
eventually and you can sort of see the
picture and black is going to get mated
everyone sees that okay let me just get
rid of these arrows um that's the
problem so it's very important to you
know realize what's coming at you and
it's not it's not that well it's not
like a very concealed plan I mean f5 you
know take space in the king side and
usually people try to play on the part
of the board where they have space and
that's really the only part of the board
white can play on the cans break through
in the center even though they're rooks
are attacking that pawn and there's
certainly not stronger on the Queen side
so question is what should black do and
in the in the game I simply didn't come
up with any effective antidote to
White's plan and I got into basically a
losing position with precisely the kind
of stuff I showed you it wasn't obvious
to me you know I what I did I played a
four I played a three you know I forced
white to put a pawn on b3 so I fixed the
Queen side pawn structure in a favorable
way for myself and we can you know we
can see that in a shortly but
unfortunately um you know the game was
going to be taking place on the Kings
side not on the Queen side so that was
the problem for black so I showed this
game to my coach and he came up with a
plan that I didn't think about it all
and the computer doesn't even offer in
the beginning one of his first impulse
buy
the way I was to try to like okay you
play rugby seven for example and you try
to run yeah you try to run from that
dangerous part of the board to part of
the board where you're better protected
practically speaking that also was not
so easy because once your King gets the
Queen side whites actually going to try
to open up the Queen side with moves
like a three and okay if you have your
pawn on a four hmm
white um well let's say you get your
pawn to a4 and a3 because basically in
order to put your King onto the Queen
side you need to close up the Queen side
right so you can't be allowing white to
have a 3 and B 4 ideas and opening up
any lines there when your King is there
so you're going to have to you know get
your pawn to a3
what white will play b3 and keep it
closed but even at that point the Queen
can come back to a square like c1 so
let's say rook e1 Queens e1 Queen c1 and
nice b1 and you still have a problem
with your a3 pawn so there were some
practical difficulties in escaping with
the King towards the towards the Queen
side so then if you can't escape you've
got to stay and fight right that's the
only other option and so he suggested
this move okay rook d7 Queen e2 and King
h8 well white continues their plan g4
rook g8
well I should actually comments on these
moves because they're not obvious ah
have you guys ever seen anything like
this because I hadn't I mean it's a rare
it's a rare idea I mean of course you
know it's a common idea to put the King
on h8 and the rook next to him when you
know there is a an open file next to the
I in front of the king so you're trying
to make the King safer right that's
obvious but when there is a pawn there
it's not obvious at all that your
approach should be to put the Tuck the
King away into the corner and then put
the rook next to him like that I mean
there's no open file and instinctively
you don't think about moves like that
because you know that rooks like open
files so what's the idea behind this
move
well white still can't play g5 because
they don't have it well enough protected
they're going to have to support that
move with Queen III and the idea behind
this move is to support the push of the
Jeep on so you're going to fight back on
the King side and you're not going to
let white get the space advantage that
they're hoping for on that part of the
board now the only question is there's a
practical question here which is which
way exactly it should black halt White's
advance here should he played g6 or
should he play g5 both of those moves
look possible
- serious about opening this line 36
well if you play g5 and your only
concern is that white is going to close
up this part of the board then you can
consider your plan to have been a total
success right because your whole dream
is black you're not trying to win on the
kingside if you can just stop white from
winning on that part of the board then
you have no nothing to fear here right
White has no no white spawns are going
nowhere and you're going to switch your
attention to the Queen side now and I
think if you know if anyone has a more
promising position it's going to be
black because there's more of a plant
they're more plans for black than they
are for white White's only plan was
playing on the kingside there's I like
the move g5 guys but unfortunately
there's a tactical problem with it
otherwise it'd be a perfectly good move
you're putting pawns in the dark squares
you're threatening to take if white
advances it's certainly not a problem
for you just like we saw there's a
tactical problem with it and that is
pawn takes pawn and the way you'd like
to recapture is with the rook right you
want that rook to be on that semi-open
file but unfortunately there's a little
problem on the D file and your queen is
trapped
it has force to go to the back rank and
there's a skewer
that's not a skewer this is a pin I
always mix those things up yeah there's
a pin on the Queen and you wind up with
an extra piece so that's unfortunate
positionally speaking though guys um you
know nothing wrong with the move g5 it's
just a little tactical problem in this
particular position so and if they take
you don't really want to take with the F
pawn I mean that's not perfect because
first of all you know it's sad for the
rook to be closed up on this file White
has a strong protective past pawn and f5
so you haven't quite accomplished what
you wanted so this is not ideal I mean
okay it's not losing for black yet but I
wouldn't consider this to be the
solution to Black's problems so
of elimination black starts with a move
g6 here now if white takes of course you
take with the rook and your rook you see
has found a very good function on the
board I mean white certainly does not
have a free rein on the kingside like
they were intending to yes now it
doesn't work I think yes it doesn't work
because the Queen has a square knot on
the back rank and the Queen there's no F
pawn in this variation right there's no
white pawn and f5
Queen is able to escape so there's no
tactic what else can white do well first
of all these moves are possible white
can you know really just go full force
ahead tactical move because obviously
after you take like on f5 the Jeep on g5
pawn starts to hang and basically in
these complications black is okay so
we're not looking at every single move
here we're just trying to understand the
idea and on a move like Bishop f3 seems
very logical to try to support that G
pawn black can simply capture that's
blacks idea I mean they're intending to
open up the G file but their work is in
a very good position for the opening up
of that file if white takes with a G
pawn you know you can actually just
compare this with what I got later on in
this game here White's rooks are not
able to just get control over the G file
Black has a rook on g8 and the problem
was that in the game it was white who
had a pawn on g5 and the rooks lines up
on the G file and White was able to
capture on f6 of their convenience and
get gain control over that file but here
if you're playing g6 yourself and taking
on f5 then obviously white is not going
to get that same control over the G file
if white tries to capture this way which
was actually the point of this move to
keep g4 protected now why it's opening
up that bishop you know nice
illustration of
lacks counter plays with this move efore
again you've got three pieces attacking
that pawn only two protecting but
because of the counter play against the
g4 pawn which you're going to win in the
end after the different captures you
know black is doing fine and if they
don't capture on e4 well you've got a
great central square for your queen so
it's looking pretty good so I don't know
if you guys are in awe of this solution
yet but honestly I was I don't know
because is I've never seen anything like
it in chests maybe that's a limitation
of my chests and knowledge but you know
it's not it's not that common of an idea
this King h8 rug g-eight given that
there is no open file inside and you're
the one who's actually going to be
creating it this is a pretty strong
prophylactic plan and the main thinking
behind this move is really like what is
whites dangerous plan well why does have
that dangerous plan of expansion on the
kingside and it's very dangerous when
you allow your opponent to get such a
big space advantage so King h8 rook g8
g6 is an attempt to stop white from
getting that overwhelming space
advantage on the King side and I can
just show you what happens when um I
didn't deal with that plan so it didn't
strike me as all that dangerous seems
like like a long way in the future I
thought okay well let me play on the
Queen side make my position better there
so my idea is a three and white really
can't push any pawns in the Queen side
because they're just you know that he
weakens too many squares so white stays
put he just follows through with his
plan sorry we're an f5 and a4 we're
going to promote this variation a Ford
Queen e2 a3 so White's got to keep the
Queen side closed b3 so I was feeling
pretty happy here I put a lot of pawns
in the dark squares I fixed even more of
White's pawns on the light squares wit
and I
envisioning you know of course if black
ever lives to see the endgame endgame is
going to be very good for black with
such great Knights and that weakness on
a - and the bad bishop on G - so from
that point of view you know positionally
speaking it's not a bad idea the problem
is it does nothing against White's plan
so and once I got it you know how do I
break through I can't really break
through on the kingside sorry on the
queenside or in the center and I was
kind of stuck at this point for a plan
so now I go King me cheap
my opponent plays Queen III now I'm a
little bit slow I think to try the rook
d7 to g8 rook g8 idea although maybe we
still yes I'm a little slow with that so
now I now my Knights are looking perfect
but they're not going anywhere so I
decided I was going to try to transfer
one of them to d4 well that's a good
idea
the knight would be well placed there
and if the Knights there takes pressure
off of the d6 pawn so you don't have to
worry about protecting it but it takes a
long time so really couldn't afford such
things white plays very directly Knight
C to a6 in fact I think I just realized
there was a problem with playing this
kind of move right because I had that
pawn hanging right away on d6 so I have
to show you these bad moves before when
I did the lecture I just kind of like
fast forwarded to the next position I
want to show you but fine I'll just show
you these next bad moves that I made um
we're after g4
- yeah oh I really didn't play this part
of the game very well G for I played my
knight back to c5 okay so I don't know
what what to do
Bishop to f3 no dude more time wasting
great g5 very impressive okay well the
problem is I just didn't know what to do
you know I the Queen side was fixed in a
nice way for me but I couldn't break
through there I couldn't play in the
center and I didn't come up with a plan
of trying to fight back on the kingside
yet so I was just kind of moving my
Knights around my opponent starts to
maneuver the knight into H 592 yeah
let's just walk by these moves um I
forgot how bad this part of the game was
for me c5 finally okay this Knight gets
here okay now this night we do a little
Knight switch finally I did I did you
know puttin this knight on d4 so so here
is a you know White's build-up white is
not in a hurry to take on f6 they're
going to do it when they are going to
have good control over that file rogue
g1 um rook g8 so I did play this stuff
but only as a purely defensive only as a
purely defensive setup to guard the g7
square not trying to at this point it's
too late to go for things like g6
because the nice already on h5 and you
have a problem with the f6 pawn so
there's no chance for black to actually
get any any counter play here on this
part of the board so that's the problem
so Brooke g8 rook here Knights my nights
are pretty good the problem is that's
not the part of the board where the game
is going to be concluded
Bishop d1 so the bishop on d1 not an
amazing piece still but he does a pretty
good job of controlling the Knights a
bit so let's walk through this part this
was kind of the time pressure part rook
a to rook F to rook AF fades okay so I
don't have nothing to do here actually
guys other than kind of wait for white
to decide when he's going to open up the
position and because it's time pressure
this was like move 40 right here on my
opponent didn't really change anything
and rook FG 2 would be a fade so here we
go King H 290 c6 well you can see black
is a force a total passivity finally
white takes black takes where are there
we go
Queen G 1 mm-hmm
this was the whole point of his little
Queen maneuvers 28 guarding the rook on
g89 g7 threatening 96 Knight d4 okay
yeah this was an interesting part of the
game so kind of there were two main
things from this game the first was the
critical moments where I didn't find the
right plan the part I showed you now I
didn't really comment because there
wasn't that much to comment on and this
part of the game was interesting for a
different reason
it's kind of like the UM was one of the
prettiest defenses I've ever come up
with so I thought even though it's not
perfectly in line with the instructive
part it's certainly aesthetic so we're
going to take a look at it Knight d4 h5
and Queen a8
I always get lost over here Queen a aids
in Queen III okay so what can I say
about this position guys I was feeling
like I have some resources for defense
here especially when my queen got to
that long diagonal and I'm threatening
this pawn my opponent defended it with
Queen III and I played uh-huh yeah this
is what I've been counting on well Queen
III is a very logical move so the funny
thing about this position remember many
moves ago I had conceived this plan of
pushing up that a pawn and I had been
counting on this pawn to help me out in
the endgame and basically I mean it's a
very strong pawn it gives black a lot of
tactical chances there's always you know
ideas of like sucking a knight there to
get a path pawn winning this pawn and
for example here is the first moment
that that a3 pawn has come in handy so I
can capture the pawn on a 2 here because
if the rook captures my Knights it's the
rook has been deflected I can capture
back the knight on g7 and I'm safe like
I'm not getting needed here so I'm able
to make that Knights capture because of
this tactical tactical reason now white
made this move rook g4 it's a little
it's kind of a slow move in a very short
position but what can white do well
White's natural try is this move Queen
to h6 dangerous square for the Queen to
get to and I'm sure my opponent didn't
play this move because he was afraid of
this pawn being captured and the Queen
coming in with all these checks and
looks like Black has a lot of counter
play so I can totally understand you
know why he wouldn't want to go for this
but whites um doesn't have to be afraid
of this because of this move rook g4 so
they're guarding the fourth-ranked if
white hurries and makes a move like this
which by the way is a dangerous
attacking idea that white has finally
opening up the G file the idea is well I
mean there are a lot of ideas really at
this point there is queen of six
threatening mates
rook takes g8 rook takes G a trick G a
king j Queen g 7 is another mate um the
problem is this was a little too slow
right because of that Queen move and you
even have a nice clean sacrifice for two
rooks so you've gotten rid of those
dangerous rooks and you've got two rooks
for the Queen the attack is pretty much
gone and we can't forget you know this
pawn which is really going to decide the
game I mean there are a lot of things
hanging in White's position here and
it's okay to lose one pawn because we've
got everything protected so black is
winning okay so he that's the reason
that in this position a rook g4 is the
strongest move now I'm pretty sure to
both of us it seemed like well work g4
the idea is then to play ninety eight
but I was going to capture this pawn and
make an attack on his Queen so when he
captures I capture it looks like black
is okay like everything is sort of
guarded and not a big problem but waits
that Bishop comes into the game with
pretty deadly force because I don't have
a lot of ways to stop in Queen h7 mate
so I got a block with this pawn in order
to give the e5 squared of the queen with
check so it's still looking pretty okay
for black because the Queen can now come
back to defend and you know what's the
problem well there is a problem
there's more stuff raining down on black
this is kind of like the final thing I
mean you know we're I guess this is
where six moves in into this variation
with Queen nations this is not that easy
so even like in Grandmaster games it
wouldn't be that easy to look that far
ahead and to realize okay that in this
position yes there is this as well and
this move wins for whites because of
this this is all fours here here and
finally the pawn comes into play and
white wins well but you can see like I
just trying to explain to why my
opponents and sort of in the heat of the
battle he took time to play this move he
wanted the e4 pawn protected so he could
play queen aged six with leisure you
know and queen aged six immediately you
know he didn't like because of this and
it looked like the Queen was coming in
and it's true you know just purely
visually it looks like black just made a
great move right it turns out that Queen
e4 is a losing move because of this
variation that I just showed you with
room g4 knight of five out of five
Bishop c2 but still doesn't mean the
black was losing after Queen h6 black
still holds the balance the black has to
deal with a very strong idea of ninety
eight that move basically like
interfering with blacks lines of
communication on the eighth-ranked and
opening up I mean just so you get an
idea what we're threatening like if we
make some random moves like moving the
knight back so you can clean your pawn
this move works because you're basically
getting to the f6 square you take it
with the Queen yes I take take and I get
to f6 so I'm not that's why this uh is
so dangerous so black has one defense
rook f7 you've got to remove that rook
from it's dangerous position on f8 and
make sure it's going to be there to
guard the the pawn on f6 so now this
stuff doesn't work anymore because you
don't have a rook hanging on the square
with a check so you can afford to just
make a capture there's no
Queen takes f8 winning here if white
recaptures now you take the knight
everything's protected you win so black
is still not losing after Queen 86 rook
f7 holds the balance alright but my
opponent played rook g4 and protected
that pawn so I moved my knight back to
b4 and he played Queen age 6 so remember
this defensive idea I got to use it here
I moved my Brook out of the way and he
played 96 so
I don't want to take that ninth because
the epon will just be very dangerous and
f6 there's a problem with that so I
captured this way my work was hanging
what's white threatening in this
position
that's the rook g7 or g7 it looks like a
pretty much a winning move for a white
right yeah looks pretty winning okay
well there's no really good defense to
that move I can't stop it from being
played by the way I can't stop it with a
move like Queen a7 because my queen
needs to be on the eighth rank and if I
let that Knights come to f8 now the
Knights arrival on g6 on the next move
is going to be very unpleasant not to
mention you know there's 1957 as well
you know that's another little
unpleasant move so my queen can't leave
the eighth-ranked to stop the move of g7
so I really can't do anything about it
so I play to the work comes in so is it
time to resign not never resign well
it's almost time to resign unless you
for seen like one defense here there is
a defense for black so White's
threatening mate in one if you capture
the rook it's also mate in one
do you have to depreciate you have to
play Quinjet it's the only move that
stops the maid so yeah this is what I
wanted to show you this part of the game
guys because it's one of the nicest
moves I've ever had a chance to make and
you know of course I had to see it a
while back I wasn't like going for this
losing position and I just got lucky
with this move but it's the only move
and it's a very good defensive move so
it's a defensive Queen sacrifice you
hold your whole Kings side together and
White has nothing better than to take
your queen but in the end remember have
been pinning all my hopes on that little
pawn that moves up from a 5 and so on
that pawn is going to win the game for
black because it turns out that even
though white has that impressive Queen
and knights on on the Kings side there
are no more infiltration squares it's
not even a single check that white can
make and the a pawn is about to Queen so
white had to go from this attack and you
know the threat of checkmate to retreat
and trying to stop the a pawn Queen a
one Queen c1 looks like to be behind
past pawns
so the rook went a 7 and the Queen had
to get very passive to stop that pawn so
now it was time to wrap things up get
the Queen out of the way oh yeah well
you know it's kind of what's funny about
this game is that like when I was
playing my pawn to a3 you know I had
that kind of vision forward like I knew
that could be a very powerful pawn and
it did work out that way in the game but
it doesn't mean like my whole concept
was right um at least like I should have
taken some action on the King side first
because I was under a very dangerous
attack and he didn't he didn't sort of
finish it up right away and I got to
sort of defend in the defense defensive
part okay that was pretty nice um and
yeah my my vision sort of worked out for
the a pawn has a very nice future
doesn't it yeah 9c2 and Queen d1 so the
only thing here you know it's still a
little bit tricky because funnily enough
if you promote the pawn to a queen after
this move white still makes very
dangerous threats against your king and
you don't have a single good check and
the king is in a lot of danger the queen
and a one is sort of out of the out of
the picture so I couldn't hurry with
that so the knight moved back and the
point here is that if the Queen moves
here right I don't repeat the position
with Knight c2 but now I take this pawn
and when he tries the same idea there's
a minor detail here that my Knights not
on c2 blocking the second-ranked
it's on b3 and so I get to checkmate
first because that rank is open so I
won't demonstrate the checkmate but you
can I guess believe that a queen and a
rook and and on open lines can check me
so that's why in this position he didn't
even try going for for Queen a1 and he
kind of went for this desperado move
Queen g4 here and it's like it's funny
the King is looks like it's pretty open
but the White Queen just can't get to
him with anything you know because the
rook on a7 does such a good job also not
only supporting the pawn but also
guarding the the mate on g7 and he tried
this move but that didn't scare me
because I had seen that coming so that
was the end of the game yeah well there
wasn't much he could do you know there
was no way to try to get to that pawn
other than Queen h4 so he has pretty a
pretty neat defense you know it was one
of the very memorable game for me
because um you know I was I showed you
this part I mean I was under a lot of
pressure in this game as you could see
right on all my moves backwards and
forwards with the Knights kind of
indicated that I didn't have a plan um
and it's not that often when you're
under that much pressure in a game that
you can come back and win that's pretty
rare usually when you're have a game
like this you know you get
you get killed yeah so that was one of
my sort of my best defenses but you know
I could have improved along the way like
so you know I showed you two kind of key
moments in the game the first part and
then I tried to get a second part when I
already had the cavil defense somewhere
along the way before the time control he
could have played his attack better and
and broken through so he also was a
little bit slow on it in the moves
leading up to the time control because I
think he just thought like well let him
safely make the time control and then
win right you know usually like that's
you know I mean that's a decent strategy
but here my position by the time we
reached move 40 was already kind of
defensible so it wasn't that easy to win
anymore and it was like more more more
of a fight